okay so I want to talk today about
this new book called zone to win
organizing to compete you know in an age
of disruption the key idea here the
challenges that we're taking on the
challenge we're going to take on is you
know we see a lot of waves of innovation
coming through the culture and how the
large companies catch the next way but
used to be called the innovators dilemma
by Clayton Christensen it's an ongoing
problem
I think it's about time that we kind of
nailed it and my proposition is that
zone management will help do that so
we're going to talk about zone
management in terms of what the concepts
are how you would organize differently
from the way you might be organized
today not as differently as you might
think and then what is sewn to win in
terms of activating these ideas and
taking them forward in your company so
just to put the challenge down look
we're living in an amazing era we know
this we're watching the digital
transformation of the entire planet we
see these needs wave after wave of
digital innovation coming out cloud
computing smartphones social networks
data science Internet of Things and I
think the key thing to register here is
why is this why is it so disruptive and
the answer is these technologies are
making things that used to be very
scarce and expensive ubiquitous and
cheap so in this new world that we're
creating here automating any service
essentially using using software to
change anything it's becoming incredibly
cheap this is why a guy like Marc
Andreessen can say software is eating
the world because it's becoming
extremely prevalent because it's very
cheap to to promulgate smart phones let
us connect with anybody of a billion
people on the planet essentially for
free so all of a sudden we can now
communicate at a level of scale and
other cost that we never could before
social networks let groups of people
tap into the trapped capacity they have
in free time if you look at something
like uber or Airbnb you're seeing how
how again we're creating ubiquity and
cheapness for things that used to be
scarce and expensive data science itself
is expensive but it's allowing us to
optimize digital systems on an ongoing
basis through a machine learning so that
they get smarter and smarter and smarter
better better
the things we're gonna be able to apply
the same strategy to physical systems in
the physical world and to the net of all
these things if you want to kind of net
it out into a sentence I think it is the
design rules for how you engage with the
world are changing which means every
existing system has to be rethought from
the ground up in terms of when do we
want to adopt the new design rules how
are we going to leverage this capability
and this means you got to catch the next
wave well when you look at the history
of tech it's not it's a landscape which
is not very encouraging these are tech
leaders from the last several decades
who were leaders in their field and did
not catch the next wave and these are
not the bad companies each of the
winning time these were our best
management teams so they have to ask
ourselves the question what is so hard
here what is going on why do why do
establish enterprises have such a
challenge in catching the next wave it's
not that they're not trying to every one
of these companies had a plan to but it
didn't it didn't work so what's going on
I think our friends at McKenzie a guy
named our dad the guy and several of his
colleagues wrote a book called the
alchemy of growth and in it there's a
framework but I think Kats direct life
on what the exact challenge is for for
an established enterprise with
disruptive innovation what they said is
when you look at the annual planning
processes of a large corporation you
when they allocate resources you want to
divide up the the the pie into three
hunter return horizons and the first
horizon called horizon one means I'm
going to give you money this year and
you're gonna pay me back this year
you're going to give me more sales or
more products and I'm going to get my
return in the same year that I give you
the money most established enterprises
do extremely well here it's how they got
to be biggest how they got the statement
get to stay big the thinking for a long
time was the problem is they're not very
good at horizon 3 but it turns out
that's not true horizon threes a chance
to do advanced R&D to do to do
skunkworks kinds of ideas actually large
companies do very well here to the
challenge that they have is in the
middle it's when I want to give money to
something that's not going to make it
this year it may break even next year
probably not quite but then the
following year it's going to turn the
corner this is where we got a large
enterprises getting stuck and we in
venture capital we call this the J curve
the idea mine that J curve is you things
get worse before they get better it's a
little bit like Dante's Divine Comedy
you have to go to Inferno to get to
purgatory oh and then to Paradiso and
that's fine for venture-backed
institutions because venture capital is
designed to invest in jakers that's the
whole premise of venture capital but
public capital publicly held companies
are not and public investors get very
nervous when they see a J curve
unfolding the challenge inside the
company is it's a very expensive new
sales force you've got to put out there
new supply chain there's very little
revenue typically there's this negative
cash flow from a financial performance
point of view things look worse not
better
and so investors can often get spooked
at this time the same time the sales
team is looking at the new opportunities
and while they're very exciting they've
got a certain amount of cachet the truth
is they don't really know the people
they're supposed to be selling do these
are not their traditional customers even
in the counts where they're already
established they've got to make new
relationships probably a new building
they have to create budget before they
can compete to consume it meaning nobody
has a budget for the new stuff yet they
think it's exciting but but they haven't
actually budgeted for it so you can see
how the sales motion is going to be
longer and more complex and so the sales
people who want to make quota this year
they get cold feet and they start to
withdraw their support and then if you
look at their management teams their
management teams are saying look I have
a finite amount of talent I need to make
my number this year you know this is a
sales marketing and professional
services envelope I run I need these
people and you can't keep sending them
over to this inefficient sales motion I
will miss my number so then the sales
management itself withdraws support so
very come this dynamic happens over and
over and over again and the key insight
here is it's not an RD problem not to
say that it can't be R&D challenges as
well but primarily it's a go to market
challenge and so how the real question
we have to face
have you solved the go-to-market
challenge of horizon - that's the
problem statement the way to think about
it is if you have a sustaining
innovation that's not disruptive you can
think of life as a funnel and horizon 2
is simply a stopping point or at stage
on the journey from horizon 3 to arisin
1 but if you have a disruptive
innovation
it's an hourglass and horizon 2 is a
bottleneck and getting through the
horizon to bottleneck is the thing that
most established enterprises failed to
do its what those 54 companies on that
earlier slide failed to do so ok so
great that's the challenge how are we
going to solve for this and the key idea
behind solving it if the notion that
when you look inside the enterprise
there are areas of activity that has to
be managed separately and the first key
idea is you've got to separate the work
that you're doing sustaining your
existing businesses from the work that
you would do to disruptive stuff and
that's pretty obvious most companies by
the way do this automatically they they
have an established set of relationships
and procedures and processes and funding
and they're typically in buildings a
through n and then the disruptive
innovations are typically done in a
skunkworks environment somewhere off off
to the side or whatever and people keep
them separate because disruption is not
in sustaining don't get along very well
the other place we which have to be
thoughtful about though is what are the
organizations that are producing the
revenue that we're counting on this year
versus where are we making enabling
investments are just frankly spending
money on cost centers when you use this
two-by-two matrix
300 organizations come into view very
quickly and they should be very familiar
to anybody on this call who works in a
large corporation the first we call the
performance zone this is this is our
horizon one zone and this is where the
people who make what you sell and sell
what you make live they live in the
performance zone and we haven't dig into
each of these zones a little bit
just a minute but if you have a number
in your compensation plan if you have a
revenue number because you own a product
line or you have a bookings number that
you own a sales responsibility or a
territory you're in the performance zone
if you don't have a number in your comp
plan you're probably in the productivity
zone the productivity zone is all of the
cost centers that work behind the scenes
to do all the work that's necessary to
make the performance zone successful so
this you will see will dig into this a
bit to marketing finance legal the
facility's customer support anything
that doesn't have a number it's part of
the the current so way of doing business
is in the productivity zone and those
two together are really the bulk of any
large corporation by far but most large
corporations in an age of disruption
have also funded an incubation zone and
this could be R&D labs but in addition
to that it could be skunkworks it could
be small tuck-in acquisitions
it could be groups that are going off
and exploring new things and and and
they're funded separately and and their
their resources are kind of highest off
from the rest of the corporation and
they're supposed to be agile and fail
fast and move fast
and those three zones show up in most
large corporations today and they're
relatively stable and people have
relatively really good confidence that
they know how to run them it's the
forces of the cause of the issues the
force zone we call the transformation
zone its horizon - this is where you
solve for the problem of the J curve and
horizon - that's unlike the other three
it's not the real zone meaning it's it
blinks in and out because there's no
building for the transformation zone the
transformation zone is actually being
the number one agenda item on the CEOs
to-do list but it's not it's not a
separate organization as we're going to
see when we look into that so the
challenge then is going to be each of
these zones has their own mission and
PlayBook we're going to be particularly
interested in the transformation zone
but frankly cuz most of us on this call
don't work there that we work in
the other three zones but I first want
to do is talk about how your zone can up
its game so that when you come to do a
transformation your company had can have
more successes so I'm gonna talk briefly
about the other three zones then we'll
then we'll take a deeper dive into the
transformation zone so each zone has its
own mission let's talk about the
performance zone this is one that's very
familiar to anybody in it the job here
is to deliver bookings revenues
contribution margins and arisin was in
most performance zones we are organized
around numbers so you can see we have
numbers of this thing the columns in
this matrix are people who sell stuff
and the rows are people who make stuff
and the Baker's have to make a number
they their compensations design they're
making a revenue number the sales
people's compensation is based on making
a bookings number is all supposed to add
up to the annual plan and when you look
at that model you say okay so how does
it work the model is based on
performance metrics this is not about
coming by this is not about a happier
customer or whatever this is about
bookings revenue contribution margins
churn growth rate it's a very
mathematical exercise it's a data-driven
exercise you either did or did not make
your number now the key places if you
look at this they most people understand
this is not Luna's but there are places
where people get sloppy with the
performance tone one is on this notion
of interlock in this model every school
every row and every column is
responsible for the squares on its row
or column and there should be a single
point of control a single person who
owns all the column all of one column or
all one row and they have the number at
the end of the row of the column when
they intersect when I cut wherever a
column intersects a row there are two
owners and interlock means that both
owners accept joint responsibility for
making the number in that cell for every
quarter and at the end of the year and
so that's called cell level interlock or
what that does is that creates immediate
visibility and account
as to where we're making our numbers and
where we are no no roller columns should
be less than 10% of the total that's a
key idea because otherwise this matrix
becomes unmanageable you have tiny
little rows that are spread across many
columns
nobody can pay attention to them the
same thing with a tiny column spread
across many rows if it's not at least
10% of your of your of your opposite
numbers quota then it's just very very
hard to pay attention to it so no sub
scale things and the idea here is you
review this once a week probably just
inside the sales organization but once a
month and then it certainly wants a
quarter where you do a readout and say
where are we in which of these cells are
we green in which are we read in which
were yellow now I have red here as a
cover for the row but I mean red yellow
green in terms of a stoplight so when
you do this this kind of mistakes people
make and this is the kind of thing you
can probably see in your organization
allowing subscale columns or rows into
the matrix you have a product line that
is it's a new products it's maybe one or
two percent of revenue and you've put it
into the performance zone it'll get lost
so it's just you you you've got it
cannot be it's got to be at least ten
percent it's going to get lost so you
have to solve for that problem
the incubations don't help solve for it
at the beginning the transformation zone
helps solve solve for it at the end but
you can't just put it in the performance
tone assigning row responsibility junior
executives you have to seem like a
product line manager owning a row and
they're going up against the senior vice
president of sales it just doesn't work
you have to have general managers
running the rows and probably worst of
all this failure to secure in a lock
most companies say well if you make your
Green number if the column guy makes his
number why do we really care whether
what rows it comes from but then you
leave the row people completely out to
lunch so it's very important to
interlock if you do get interlocked
you're going to get early detection of
performance misses which is great which
means you can correct them before before
you know the end of the year your swift
remedial action can happen at the cell
level and you get increasingly reliable
forecasting so good discipline in the
before
zone is important that said if you're
not being disrupted this year you can
probably get away with somewhat sloppy
behavior that's how companies get sloppy
but in it but under the pressure of
disruption you won't be able to do that
so these are good or good principles to
up your game right now maybe even if
you're not being disrupted to get ready
to be disrupted okay we'll go to the
next one so the productivity is known
most of the people on this call I
suspect are in the productivity zone
the job here is to produce programs and
systems for compliance efficiency and
effectiveness so if you look at this
kind of organizations we see in the
productivity zone you know marketing
central engineering procurement customer
support enterprise IT quality control
supply chain Human Resources legal
facilities administration of Finance I
suspect many of you are out here and you
say okay so what do we owe what's our
mission
what's our what is this when they give
us funding horizon 1 what do they want
back from us and they went back to risk
one one or more of three things they
would like you to make our performance
zone and in fact our whole company more
effective and do that by delivering
programs and I'll say some more words
about programs in just a minute also we
need to make ourselves more efficient
and that requires systems and I'll say
some more words about that in a minute
and then we also need to maintain
regulatory control so please monitor and
verify compliance so that we don't have
to go to jail now the last one is sort
of non-negotiable and it just has to be
done it has to be done correctly but
there's a lot of discretion around the
first two how do you invest again
efficiency and effectiveness how do you
best about the assistance and programs
and when we look into the productivity
zone and we look at how things get a
little bit sloppy here and what what
what you have to where you have to up
your game if you're going to be
entertaining a disruptive innovation the
key idea here is programs and systems
are actually very different animals I'll
cut both of these up and walk you
through the comparison a program is
designed to change the state of
something change the state of a customer
change the state of an organization
change the state of a partner and
the the person is funding the program is
buying that change of state from the
people who are producing the program
this program here I want to change my
state as an employable individual was
change my state as a as an innovator in
order to corporation that's why I'm
taking a class from Stanford that kind
of idea a system is designed to maintain
state it doesn't change David maintain
state it keeps things running as they
are so if you look at programs they
should be optimized for effectiveness
that in effectively making the change
worse systems would be optimized for
efficiencies and programs are highly
customized it's very important that they
meet the users needs systems are very
standardized and in fact the user has to
adapt to the system in order for it to
be efficient and and so as a really
should be funded by the person who wants
the change so the state it's usually in
the office it's a salesperson in the
performers own or a product person in
the performance tone they need a
marketing program where they did a
hiring program or whatever it is they
need to change the state of their
organization or change the state of
their customer or market and system
should be centrally funded and they're
largely internally focused and they're
designed to make us more efficient so
the key idea here is you attack problems
with programs and then you lock the
solutions in with systems you can't and
the key ideas do not blend them most of
the slippage that we see in this zone
where you where you just get frustration
both inside the zone and within the
customers of the zone also get
frustrated is we end up matching systems
against program problems or programs
against systems problems or we just
don't make the distinction at all and we
just throw money at something we'll take
a program budget and use it to repair a
system that kind of stuff it creates all
kinds of dissatisfaction so the kinds of
mistakes that we see the that you might
want to test for in your organization
again particularly if you're going into
a disruptive period do we are we are we
actually rolling out a system and with
the idea that we have a changed state a
lot of people did this you know we're
gonna roll out a big our ERP system and
change the state of our company no
you're not an ERP system maintained
state if you want to change the state
you have to do a change management
program first and then put the system in
behind it the second one and the ones
it's kind of the saddest one is you run
programs they're very good programs
everybody likes them the kind of like
Barney programs everybody likes
everybody but they don't change anything
so you go to the program and you don't
you know achieve a change in state that
was a waste of time and then the last
one is systems that accommodate too many
exception conditions where basically
what we have a system but I like to do
it my way or in my country we do it
differently and all of a sudden whatever
efficiency goals you had are out the
window because you don't really have a
system you have many systems and there's
huge exception routines and now you have
just a raft of people working through
the exception so if you can nail the
program systems distinction and you can
nail the deployment of programs and
systems effectively you'll get faster
and more agile responses to emerging
requirements because you'll be able to
put a program right on it you'll have
greater impact on the performance zone
and you'll have more efficient use of
funds with because you'll put the system
in behind the program capture the gains
of the program and then run it run it
going forward so again I'm just giving
you kind of a flavor of each one of
these things because we're going to get
to the transformation zone is the main
idea here but I want to give you a
flavor that even business as you and
again if you're not terrific at this in
your company right now and you're not
being disrupted you can get away with a
lot of sloppy behavior here but if you
get disrupted and all of a sudden
resources become very scarce this you're
gonna wish that you've done some some
cleanup before that had begun so now
look at the incubation zone so the
incubation zone is a very different
Charter it's typically much smaller to
relatively small amount the total budget
and it's been hive dog this nut doesn't
have a number it has a different kind of
accountability it's job is to
essentially catch the future in a bottle
and create options for the company to
potentially participate in the next wave
of disruption and the idea is not to
catch every way the idea is not to be
caught flat-footed
so you want to at least have a sense of
what the way it's about and then from
that inventory you'd like to eventually
pick ways that you are going to
meant to sew in that world one of the
lessons we've had is we used to do this
with labs we'd say we'd have an R&D lab
and there were Bell Labs IBM labs HP
labs Nokia etc etc the challenge with
the lab is that by the time you get
something out of the lab and so it's
still so immature you can't really
transition the technology to a division
so what we've learned in the last 10 or
15 years is you're better off in the
incubation zone building independent
operating units that look a lot
most-loved like startups so what you
want to do is kind of copy the mentor
the venture capital people here then you
can even off and start these by doing a
small tuck in acquisition you buy a
small company to kind of get it and get
it going but you want to have a general
manager and all of the sales and
marketing and engineering and services
and support services that you need to
run a little startup should all be local
to that to that that effort the second
thing you need to do is you need to put
this funding under a car a separate
entity this should not be part of the
annual funding process this needs its
own incubation fund its own adventure
style fund and when the idea here is
that then anybody in the company can
pitch the incubation fund just like a
like that at a shark tank where you know
you can come and say listen III think I
have a great idea we should you should
incubate it as an independent operating
unit that then creates a point of
control for this yeah a lot of creative
people in your company and right now
they don't know where to go with it with
it with an idea and so as a result you
have a lot of people running around this
is a great way to centralize and control
it and then the third thing is these
independent operating units need special
attention they can't really participate
in the standard finance the standard HR
the standard administration the standard
annual planning process and so what you
want to do is put a liaison group which
essentially is designed specifically to
make sure that we don't go to jail with
what these people do but to give them
services that are more flexible and more
oriented toward a startup thing so this
is a way this is this is kind of how a
venture firm is organized and there's a
way to take this and put this inside a
company some of the key ideas the i/o
you see general managers not RD
technical project leads entrepreneurs
is where you want to have an
entrepreneur who is building a business
and so that's why they have to have all
the functions reporting in to them
that's how they can learn fast that's
how they can do the Lean Startup Minimum
Viable Product
you know minimum who's getting through
it some people are now calling the
traction gap to get the minimum viable
traction that whole idea and so the way
you fund these things is instead of
saying well you have a year's worth of
funding it's much more this is why you
need an incubation run with a board you
do the venture style funding I will give
you seed funding to see if you can give
me a proof of concept I will give you a
Series A funding to see if you can give
me a Minimum Viable Product and some
early customers Series B maybe you could
win an entire beachhead market that's
where you would cross the chasm
potentially seriously maybe you exit the
scale but the point is you don't do this
as part of an annual process these
things typically do not take a year and
it's very important to hold IO use
independent operating units accountable
to hit in their milestone or frankly not
getting funded or or maybe getting one
more chance at a bite of the Apple but
not just getting an annual annual read
up as it were so the funding and reviews
happen outboard of the annual clam and
then it turns out that there's a lot of
ways you think you can exit from this
process so the one that we're betting on
the one we're going to get to next is
you go into the transformation zone your
independent operating unit is the unit
that we bet on big at the corporation
that's the whole point in a sense of the
zone but there are five other exits that
are that are that are also viable and
the second one is actually often more
common and highly valuable and that is
well we didn't actually decide to bet on
your business as a new business but we
think you've invented something that we
can incorporate into one of our existing
businesses and give it what we would
call it good life kicker so it's not a
home run and the home run is
transformation zone but it's a single or
maybe even a double it's it's actually
it's a big debt so it's actually quite a
good thing and a lot of innovation ends
up going into the performance zone and
it's very very welcome when it does but
it doesn't disrupt now now you're
accommodating the existing business
you're not disrupting some of the
technology actually doesn't get
commercialized so it doesn't go to the
transformation zone of the purple
go to a revenue path but it still can be
used internally for a lot better
productivity and so another way you can
take some of these technologies it's
take that into the productivity zone so
these are three very positive outcomes
going forward a fourth thing is you know
you did a great job
it just isn't us we're not going to make
this bet for whatever reason but we
think this is a bet worth making if why
don't we spin you out and let private
capital outside of the company to take
you forward and see where you can go and
and you know come unleash unleash the
Kraken as it were the fifth thing is
well it didn't work as well as we hoped
but you made some assets we can sell
them and the sixth one is hey you know
we tried it didn't work we're going to
shut it down the point is that there are
very clear exits in this thing and what
the board has to do is what we call
embed your force and exit what you
cannot allow these things to do is just
stay in place these spaces in the
incubation zone are so valuable it's
important to turn them over rapidly and
to get a result one of these six results
going forward so again if your
knightress if you're not doing this
typically if you don't have an
incubation zone you what will happen is
you'll you'll protect these things for a
while but sooner or later you'll expose
them to the performers own and the
performance on will say well where are
the numbers and the numbers that won't
look very good and so you're going to
have a lot of things that die on the
vine because they just can't it's
premature to put them in the performance
on but you have no other place to put
them when you share go to market
resources with the performers own you
also have the problem that at the end of
the day their first job is to make their
number you're not gonna really help them
make their numbers so you get second
priority on go to market when you're a
young startup that's added that's death
this is why startups routinely beat
large companies because in a start-up a
true startup a venture-backed startup
there's only one place that everybody in
that company has only one goal that
they're aligned around they may not
succeed but they're not conflicted you
know a large company there are virtually
always conflicted and then the third
thing is we were really holding the io
u--'s accountable for venture milestones
we would account them we have something
called stage gates stage gates are good
for sustaining innovation for that
funnel they are not good for
disruptive innovation venture milestones
or what you want there now if you do put
this thing in place you're going to get
some really exciting returns this
playbook this notion of adopting the
venture play but it can be very powerful
in your company viable business with
very high growth rates it is obviously
the key idea but also products to
supplement existing businesses and also
technology to improve productivity so
there's a lot to gain here again right
now most companies don't do anything
quite this formal and as a result their
innovation efforts are interesting but
boy it's hard to get traction with them
without something like this to put in
place okay so those are the three zones
that we you see there are separate areas
of your corporation you can probably
find these in different buildings and
you can probably make a pretty clear
determination is my job in the
performance zone and the productivity
zone or in the incubation zone the
fourth zone is the one that's been the
real challenge we'll call it the
transformation zone and the key
deliverable here we're going to see
there's actually two versions of this
but the key one the one that people care
the most about is we're gonna take a
disruptive innovation and we are going
to make it into a material business we
are going to be it is going to be our
next big thing the way Apple made the
iPod their next big thing and then they
made the iPhone their next big thing
after that and then they made the iPad
their next big thing after that the way
Amazon said with AWS but as we know
they're not a lot of companies that have
done this and so why is this so hard so
what we're going to try to do here is
we've got to see what's suppose we've
got an incubation zone of some kind and
we've been developing horizon three
independent operating units in the zone
and we have a performance matrix in the
performance tone in horizon one so the
goal of the transformation zone is to
take a business out of the horizons rate
incubation zone through the
transformation zone and have it land as
a as a fully fledged business in the
performance matrix meaning it's 10% or
more of total revenue by the time we
unleash it it kind of let it let it
graduate if
welcome the transformation zone so what
we're going to do is we're going to
navigate the bottleneck in the hourglass
this is the mechanism by which we solve
for the bottleneck so what exactly are
we going to do in the transformation
zone so the key idea here is this is not
business as usual so let me kind of walk
through these ideas the first idea is if
you started transformation that
commitment trumps all other commitments
now the commitment is to scale the new
business to ten percent of total revenue
failure is not an option what that means
is everybody's badge is on the table
it's not just the leader of the
independent operating unit and the CEOs
who are trying to get this done every
direct report on the executive staff has
to have a stake in this game because
every one of them can make a
contribution and more importantly if any
one of them withhold even a little bit
of support they can create just enough
inertia to make sure it never happens so
making the horizon one number if you're
in the performance zone because they had
a sales or one of these other product
lines that are going to make room for a
new product line in the performance
though you're kind of jealous of your
resources and you say well look I
thought you can't do this to me because
I have to make my number and the answer
and if you want me to make my number and
the correct answer is of course we want
you to make your number but this is more
important than you're making your number
once we start a transformation we must
not fail and so therefore your
compensation then as you see in the
second and the second set of bullets
your compensation will be tied to this
one outcome your discretionary
compensation not all of it but enough of
it so that you will not be a very happy
person if this thing doesn't succeed and
this thing is probably going to take a
couple of years so this is a longer term
compensation but you have to have the
board of directors behind this because
it's going to take you're going to go
through a J curve it's going to put your
stock price at rest the only person has
the power to do this is a CEO you cannot
delegate this task because you're going
to ask every other zonas we'll see on
the next slide to make a sacrifice the
only person who has the authority to ask
all the three other zones to sacrifice
is the CEO so and the CEO is the only
one who can really orchestrate the shift
in resources because you
put a whole bunch of resources behind
something that at the beginning looks
totally inappropriate to get that kind
of funding this is what it's going to
take to get through the transformation
the key milestones you start with an IOU
and an entrepreneurial gem that you
believe in you're gonna grow it an order
of magnitude maybe maybe it's like 1% of
revenue that it's got into a certain
size in the incubation zone now you're
going to take it to 10% you're gonna
enter and you're probably going to do
some M&A in order to get there because
organically the bigger you are the less
likely you can do it all organically and
you're going to end this thing as a row
in the performance matrix that's what's
gonna declare victory that's what that's
what the apple of M is the next fight by
the way Apple stock price is one of a
gazillion ever went up like 50 times
when the average tech companies tech
price went up to during during the last
say 10 years and so in that model
there's a big prize that's why you can
align executive compensation could you
just give them stock stock options and
and if you if you really do expand your
portfolio there's a very big price for
everybody but only if it gets to 10% of
for more of total revenue with good
contribution margins looking like an
exciting new business the way music did
for Apple the way the way phones did for
Apple etc now this is not for the faint
of heart because everybody has to make
serious sacrifices to make this work the
performance tone has to donate 10% of
its resources to the transformation to
make the number what the other 90% is
really painful as we said that sales
motions inefficient I mean is this all
kinds of grief there the productivity is
Noah's got to develop a bunch of
programs and improve systems just to
squeeze any kind of resource to help
fund this thing and the incubation zone
it's got to realize once we've declared
one company as our focus nobody else can
compete for the transformation zone so
they have to find another exit so it's
massively disruptive across the board
that's why the CEO muscly you cannot
delegate this to anybody else nobody
else can garner the respect and you also
can never do two at the same time even
though it might seem like you're putting
all your eggs in one basket
believe me chickens lay eggs one at a
time and that's the way the best of them
all you have to have in your mind so
what happens what do people do why did
those
before companies fail most of them did
try to do more than one transformation
at a time that's a complete non-starter
it's so stressful to do one there's just
no chance you could do two they often
would do support halfway through when
you withdraw support halfway through you
signal to the world you're not quite as
committed as they thought and then
everybody was on the fence says okay and
they pull back so you never reached the
tipping point and and the other way is
you let you let one or more major
executives just say well this is not my
problem I'm not going to support this
everybody has to support it or it won't
happen you cannot have internal conflict
and normally you do have internal
conflict so big problems not trivial to
solve for us but if you do suffer them
lots of lots of prizes for success new
high growth business added to the
portfolio you know by the way that also
creates a halo effect for your existing
businesses think about the Macintosh
business at Apple a dramatic increase in
market capitalization a huge huge huge
prize so very much worth doing but but
but not but not easy so just to kind of
bring this to a close then they turn
this back over to Ronnie how does this
this frame this framework so by the way
the frame was said in the book called
own to win I'm kind of giving you a kind
of a race through it but they are
available and get in the books you want
I dig it a little deeper how do you use
these frameworks and we say to attack
defend and maintain
so the attacking idea is the one we've
been talking about so far which is we
have a star in the incubation zone
and we've decided as a management team
of the CEO leading that we are going to
make it we're gonna make this the center
of our transformational effort and so
that's become the number one priority in
our company now the performance zone is
still number two and the productivity
zone we need a lot of help from them so
that's kind of our footprint is er to
put those three together by the way the
incubation zone do not apply for any
additional funding at this time in fact
we're going to ask we may force some
additional exits in order to reduce the
drag on the other three zones and
everybody in list everyone in scaling
the new business the key idea here is
that the entire company prioritizes the
transformation zone
business regardless of what film they
live in regardless what the day job is
their number one priority becomes this
new business must get to scale no matter
what so it's a very different agenda
that has normally been used in the past
and certainly the 54 companies that
didn't attach the next way did not make
it that kind of a priority and that as a
consequence I believe that's one of the
key critical factors that caused them
not to be successful now one of the
things we learned was we were doing this
is you know sometimes it's not that you
have the disruption
it's that somebody is disrupting you so
Microsoft became a very interesting case
study in our book sales force a sort of
an example of the first of the zone
office
Microsoft became a great example zone
defense they have some very very
powerful businesses that again getting
disrupted their back office software by
Amazon Web Services and cloud in general
their office business by Google Apps
their windows business by mobile mobile
devices iOS and Android so they're under
attack so when when your business is
under attack direct attack by a highly
powerful disruptive innovation you
cannot fix that business if you leave it
in the performance zone because you've
got to do you've got to get kind of
surgery on it so the idea is and this is
what Microsoft has done they've brought
businesses into their transformation
zone and made it the number one priority
the first one they did was that their
back office software they it was all
on-premise they made Azure cloud their
priority even though Azure cloud was not
as profitable as the back office
software business they made it their
priority they've now gotten that past
the tipping point they put it back in
the performance tone right now office is
their priority again online office off
what they call office 365 not as
profitable as buying and selling it on
the devices but it is the future
bringing into the transformation zone go
through a Jaykar accept the fact that
your revenues and profits is going to go
down before they go up and move forward
by the way when you're doing this play
you go into the incubation zone and you
Rob it for any technology that can help
you modernize your existing business as
fast as possible so that's not probably
why the technology was being incubated
was probably somebody had a dream of
maybe being the disrupt tour but now
no no no we're the disrupt T we need you
to help us defend ourselves against the
disruptors and yes eventually we would
we're still worried about the
performance on but frankly we need to
get ourselves back into health so if we
have a pattern that looks like this and
under this pattern everyone has been
listed and stabilizing the current
business and and that becomes the number
one part again so the number one
priority is stabilize this business get
back to health
typically by modernizing its operating
model so that it can compete more
effectively with disrupter and then
finally there are years where you're not
being disrupted either you're not doing
it nobody's in into you so in those
years that's the year where the
performance zone is the top top making
the number is the number one priority
the productivity zone is enlisted to do
that and the incubation zone is creating
options for the future this is a time to
make money
we call it harvest your rewards build up
your reserves so this is actually a
great time for a company because you can
deliver on what your investors want all
your customers want I want your
employees one you might even get home at
night before six o'clock it's a great
time so just to recap and I'll turn it
back over to Ronnie the challenge again
the waves of innovation I think are
inescapable the design rules for the
world are changing the challenge when we
double-click on it is this horizon 2
problem
the zone management framework is
designed to cope with that problem by
isolating two of the horizon 1 zones the
performance on where you deliver the
number the productivity zone where you
do all the work behind the scenes as
well as isolating the incubation zone
where you create options for the future
and then the key idea is the
transformation zone which isn't really
an organizational zone as much as it's
the CEOs number-one priority for the
company that's how the zones work and
then we just saw it right here that you
can either do that zone offense where
you are the destructor zone defense when
you're the disrupt e or between waves
when you're essentially working and you
know working we're essentially making
hay while the sun is shining so that I
want to say first of all thank you very
much for using the opportunity to give
this talk out we can answer some
questions here I'm going to turn it back
one of the questions that came up
Jeffrey was if you're a CFO or CEO of a
company how do you decide how much
funding you'd like to allocate to the
incubation zone and how do you measure
the success of that yeah I think it's
obviously in good years you might want
to allocate a little bit more in lean
years or less and obviously if you're
feeling disruptive closer you're going
to spend more or less
it's not much let me put it that way I
mean I would be I would say normally
that spending is going to happen in the
transformation zone so you would expect
it to be a few percent of annual revenue
but not a lot more than that the teams
frankly are what you want to keep them
small small teams are not that expensive
you might do a tucking acquisition that
you might that might be an additional
expense yeah okay do you have an example
of a product we talked briefly about
Apple you have some other examples of
successful products that went through
the incubation zone and were then moved
out yeah so if you look at this the most
of most common successes in text are
typically founder driven companies so
the Apple example cuts obviously Steve
Jobs you can turn to a Jeff Bezos at
Amazon and clearly Amazon Web Services
went through a process like this you
look at Marc Benioff at Salesforce and
and and the way with addition to how
they added marketing cloud so they
marketing clouds they bought a company
called buddy-buddy media they bought a
company called radian6 they were not
getting enough traction they were in the
incubation zone but they were not coming
together they bought a company called
ExactTarget which gave them enough mass
and then mark made that exact target the
priority for the company for two years
in a row in the transformation zone and
as a result they were able to drive that
to more than ten percent of revenue it's
now a full-fledged row in the
performance matrix but it but
classically if you don't if you don't
yeah it's a board and the CEO do not
align around this one commitment and get
everybody's everybody on the exact team
committed to it founders do that by just
by simply making life intolerable for
people if you don't commit but
but I didn't need a more organizational
approach to the problem so as a
follow-on to that one of the participant
is asking what if there is not full
alignment at the top level of the
company around making such a change are
there things that can be done on the
ground by you know what lower-level
people so the answer for transformation
zone is no and in fact I would argue
that that is the normal status quo most
companies are I mean it's fair that you
have a leader at the top who wants to
embrace transformational leaders not
that rare but let's say it would not be
an it would not be a fun surprise that
one who is more conservative if that's
the case then just don't go to the
transformation zone in other words you
take most of your innovations from the
incubation zone and slot them into the
performance zone or slop them into the
productivity zone and take advantage of
your innovation in the context of
sustaining innovations rather than
disruptive now there's one time where
you are going to need to gird your loins
is if you get directly attacked in one
of your flagship businesses by a
disrupter then zone defense does have to
be implemented and that does have to be
implemented by the CEO but I think a CEO
under attack is maybe more likely to
make these changes than a CEO who has
options okay so we have a question from
somebody who's an old employee and in a
Productivity Zone of one of the
companies and is asking how did he
recognize a company or an area that's
going to be successful in this age of
disruption if they're looking to to move
away from the productivity though okay
well before you decide to move away the
productivity is no I sure hope you give
some thought into this program system
distinction because the productivity
zone is the unsung hero of every
corporation it's actually where you can
accomplish the most change because
because because you have the most
discretion over over the funding and
what it's doing but I think in general
if you're saying look I just need to get
into a faster moving company I think to
find any company that is aligned with
one of those five ways that we talked
about cloud computing mobile computing
social network
and data Sciences or Internet of Things
and it doesn't have to be a text it's
but it's just if the company is has
riding one of those waves already
they're kind of on the wave then I think
you're gonna have if that company has a
leg up on its competition so if you have
a few products in the incubation zone
that seem to all be equally likely to
succeed how do you decide which one of
them to move to the transformation zone
it's a great question and there's not a
formulaic answer to that the point is
you have to choose one and and if you
fret too much about oh my gosh what if I
choose the wrong one just rest assured
that not choosing is worse than choosing
so so so and then the second thing is
but the worst thing you can do is to
choose to order if you did it what will
happen is all three will race for the
exit at the same time they're all
ambitious and then you'll overload the
company and then you condemn all of them
to death
so it really picking one is this knack
of courage but it's also an active of
mercy for and frankly it's increasing
your odds how about the reward system in
these different zones do they are they
different in any way totally different
so so the performance zone is all about
horizon-1 compensation rewards and
should be so sale you want salespeople
to be coin-operated that's the whole
that's the way sales comp is designed to
work and the productivity zone
frankly the rewards are largely you get
you guys you can get a bonus of shared
bonus but it's really more about is I'm
doing what I love I like being in
service to get to to my customers I like
to I like to provide the services that
we get to provide in my function and so
it's much more of a I like to I'm
getting a personal reward from that and
I'm being paid at the same time and I'm
doing interesting work the incubation
zone is it's like a venture capital
startup because if you're not going to
get stock options so if you want to get
if you want to take that kind of risk
you should actually go to form a startup
because many startups flame out and and
and that's that's a real
incubation soda inside a corporation you
you're still taking a risk but it's kind
of a guarded risk so what you get to do
the rewards there the metrics there are
about I get to create the next big thing
and I have a chance that maybe becoming
a general manager of a major business in
this company if we pick my scale right
so we have a question here about someone
interested about the your thoughts on
the 70/20/10 kind of time management
system if i did google PG&E and other
places does that fall in line with it
with this model or not other well so i
think what does that time management
system is designed to do is to share
time between the performance zone and
the incubation zone or between the
productivity zone and the incubation
zone and sort of a horizon one horizon 3
split if you will I think I think I
think do not think it answers the
transformation zone issue at all I think
in a transformation zone it's much more
about issue priority
meaning I don't if you're not if you're
not right in the middle of the
transformation business I don't need a
lot of your time I just need to be the
first I just need to have top of mind
whenever I do need your time the biggest
killer of a transformation is latency
delay I make a request and I they say
I'll help you but I can't help you this
week its death in the transformation so
that that's what that so it's not
percentage resource its prioritization
of reasons so I would like to thank
everyone again who have joined us here
online as well as Jeffrey Moore of
course for sharing his great research
and writing about this the four zones
and I encourage you all to check out our
website SCPD stanford.edu and the
remainder of our programs as well as if
you're interested please go ahead and
take a deeper dive into the into
Jeffrey's both zone to win thank you all
very much for joining us and have a good
rest of your day